Thanks to Babbel, a language learning app,
for sponsoring this episode.
If you’re interested in growing your language
skills, Microcosmos viewers get up to 60%
off with a 20 day money-back guarantee when
you sign up using our link in the description.
Our world today, the one that we have constructed,
feels as if it runs on plastic.
It is a building block in our bags, our bottles,
clothing, toys…
the list it go on and on.
Plastic has become so prevalent that it is,
for all intents and purposes,
impossible to escape.
Even in the microcosmos, plastic is inevitable.
It persists in long, still threads that
could have come from anything.
Maybe it was shed from a piece of clothing,
or it came off a car part.
Whatever it once was, this shred of microplastic
is one of many pieces just like it turning
the microcosmos into a burial ground
for our waste.
But microbes are crafty, they're capable of making
lives out of the most unusual ingredients—
including plastic.
So what does that look like, for them
and also for us?
Well, first let’s be human about it and focus
on ourselves for a bit, and particularly our
love for plastics.
We currently make around 400 million tons
of plastic every year, but why?
Well “plastics” covers a wide range of materials.
At a chemical level, they are made of structures
that repeat over and over, creating a pattern
that builds into a material that is moldable
under the right temperatures and pressures.
And nature is full of materials like this that
would end up driving our love of plastics, including
natural rubber and plant cellulose,
even wood is a chemical polymer.
But nature sets some constraints on how
much we can take, and precisely what's available.
And at the turn of the 20th century, the advances
of chemistry and the demands of war meant
that synthetic plastic was primed to take
over—
first as part of military vehicles and parachutes
and other wartime needs, and then after in
consumer goods like Tupperware.
They were cheaper and lighter than glass
and metal, and so versatile.
But while we’ve lived with the benefits
of these synthetic plastics for more than
a century now, we’re also living with their
harms.
Plastics don’t just surround us in the objects
we make, they last in these invisible forms,
smaller than 5 millimeters in length.
Some might come off our clothes when we wash
them, others might be part of our cosmetics.
They can loft into the air and come back down
with rain, or they can travel through our
waterways, ending up in ponds and oceans.
James, our master of microscopes, found most
of the samples we’re looking at today floating
in his plankton net while gathering microbe
samples.
And on their own, these small fragments of
plastic seem so inconsequential.
But in a world like ours, where everything
is connected, nothing is inconsequential.
Microplastics get eaten by animals, they
break down into chemicals that can be toxic
and those get leached into the environment.
But the consequences do not stop there.
Animals get eaten by other animals, which
then get eaten by other animals, and so on.
And with each step up and around the food web,
microplastics and their toxins accumulate.
Scientists are still working to understand
how microplastics affect our ecosystems and
our bodies.
But one of the challenges with microplastics
is just how durable they are.
Those long chains of atoms, once assembled,
tend to stay that way.
One way to curb the amount of microplastics
that end up in our world and in us is to stop
making as much new plastic and instead, you
know, recycle what we’ve already made.
Unfortunately, only a small fraction of the
massive amount of plastic we produce each
year gets recycled.
Some of the challenges are in our infrastructure,
like figuring out how to sort different types
of plastics so they can be properly recycled
without mixing them up with each other.
Some of it is technological, in finding ways
to break down the most challenging plastics,
or developing tools to ensure recycled plastic
is just as good as the original.
And that has led scientists to turn to the
microcosmos for possible answers, with one
particular question in mind:
can microbes eat plastic?
Now there are many ways to investigate
that question, and for Maria Pinto—
a scientist who has sent us samples before—
it’s taken her out onto the ocean as she
looks to see how bacteria gather on plastics.
The samples come from all over.
Some are from the Atlantic Ocean, some from
the Pacific Ocean, some from the Adriatic Sea.
The ubiquity of microplastics in her samples
feels similar to the way we find microbes
everywhere, but without the wonder and
awe that microbes inspire.
Now microbes are everywhere because they find
a way to endure, adapt, and spread.
Their ubiquity is a marker of their ingenuity.
Microplastics, on the other hand, are a product
of our ingenuity, but also of our carelessness
with our creations.
It also fits that these two pervasive
entities would find each other.
Maria has seen the bacteria gathering on microplastics,
their cellular bodies producing enzymes that
might even be able to break down the plastics
into their individual units for the bacteria to use.
Scientists are looking in plenty of other
places too.
Greek beaches.
Mud near a Japanese plastic recycling factory.
Hot springs in Yellowstone National Park.
These diverse iterations of the microcosmos
and the plastic-eating bacteria in them teach
us more about the enzymes we might be able
to use in the future to recycle plastic.
These enzymes come with their own challenges.
Some work in a narrow temperature range, others
are just kind of slow.
But the more scientists learn about
how these enzymes work,
the more they’re able to improve them—
sometimes even combining different enzymes
to make one big super plastic-digesting enzyme.
This is all necessary research, urgent
against the backdrop of every other way our
planet has been affected by human behavior.
We are still only just beginning to understand
how widespread this evolution around plastics
is, and how organisms have managed to develop
mechanisms around seemingly unnatural materials
that we’ve overwhelmed nature with.
In 2020, we knew of about 90 microbes
capable of digesting plastic,
though scientists are still trying to understand
whether all those microbes consume the parts
we want them to.
And more research searching for signs
of plastic-digesting enzymes found a correlation
between the abundance of those enzymes and
the extent of plastic pollution in a given area.
Perhaps if we understand more about how microbes
are adapting to this pollution, we’ll understand
better how we can use them.
But what does it mean to rely
on our oldest, smallest creatures
to fix our newest, biggest problems?
A bacterium can eat away at plastic, but what
comes after?
When you think of the scale of what bacteria
have done in the past, it seems possible for
them to fix things for us.
They’ve reshaped atmospheres and constructed
ecosystems, what’s a little plastic to them?
But for all bacteria can do, they can’t
run our business.
Nor can they command our infrastructure or
curb our demands.
Bacteria are not going to be our saviors,
they are simply our neighbors,
along with everything else on earth.
So to make the best use of them then requires
more than just understanding how they work.
It requires understanding ourselves, and how
we work.
Anything else, and it may not matter
what we find.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Babbel for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Are you ready to step out of your winter hibernation
and get ready for summer travel!?
Usually trying to learn a new language requires
a lot of time and commitment, making it difficult
to quickly get into conversations.
Well, Babbel is a language learning app that
helps you use a new language in real-life
situations after only five hours of practice
and it offers lessons in 14 different languages.
It’s the #1 language learning app in the
world, and with its short, interactive, 10
minute lessons, Babbel teaches more than just
vocab words.
It teaches you about the culture, people,
history and more associated with the language
you are learning.
And Babbel offers multiple ways to learn,
including podcasts, games, videos, and live
classes so you can choose whatever format
works best for you.
As a Microcosmos viewer, you’ll get up to
60% off when you sign up using our link.
Plus Babbel comes with a 20 day money back
guarantee, so you can see where Babbel takes
you on our language learning journey.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons, the people who allow
us to continue this exploration of our marvelous
world with some really fantastic equipment
and a lot of connections to scientists across
the globe.
Thank you so much for supporting us on this
journey.
It means a lot.
If you'd like to become one of these people,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.